[Music]
foreign
leaders face complexity in their
competitive environments what you see is
enormous variety of just potentially
disruptive processes going on that
really exacerbates the challenges that
leaders face
what leaders need to do is have a set of
skills for diagnosing the challenges
that they're tackling and also then
being able to translate that into an
action plan what I'd like to do is
figure out how my business unit can
contribute to my company's strategy and
align with my company's long-term goals
the main focus of this program is on the
issue of what we call alignment how do I
align my strategy to my competitive
environment and how do I align my
organizational design to the strategy
that I'm trying to pursue what is the
right leadership and what works and what
doesn't work great organizations or
well-aligned organizations
we really bring together faculty who
have devoted their careers to
understanding the kinds of challenges
that leaders face these are the guys
that wrote the cases and we're in the
room with the people who worked in the
companies so it's fantastic
the innovation in the world right now is
centered out in Silicon Valley and I see
Stanford as a hub for that one of the
great things about ebsco is the
incredible diversity of participants
participants from all over the world
from all different kinds of
organizations so much of the benefit of
the program comes from the lessons that
you learn from people in different
contexts 6 successful leadership is not
about cookie cutter Solutions we really
want to take you away from just feeding
you a standard here's what all the best
companies do to saying let's give you
the ability to build your own solution
set
each person came with different
perspectives the information on this
program will help me become a better
leader was really well-rounded Global
Experience I will treasure the rest of
my life
thank you